but we're going to begin with a very
alarming situation at a Pennsylvania
Airport where TSA workers found what
looked like explosives in a suitcase now
this man allegedly dropped off that bag
on Monday at Lehigh Valley International
Airport that's in Allentown the flight
was bound for Florida but he never got
on it 40 year old Mark muffley is now in
custody officials say that he fled when
security called his name and he was
later arrested at his home Christina
raffini is following the story Christina
not surprised that he took off
considering what he left behind very
glad he's in custody this morning good
morning to you good morning Gail yeah
the FBI says this device posed a
significant threat to passengers and the
aircraft but authorities say they still
don't know why exactly he tried to get
these explosive materials on board the
plane
yeah it's surprising surprisingly
somebody thinks they can get away with
it authorities say on Monday Mark
muffley checked in this roller bag seen
here on Airport surveillance for an
Allegiant Air flight to Orlando but
during a routine TSA screening the bag
triggered an alarm according to the
complaint TSA agents found a circular
compound wrapped in a wax-like paper and
clear plastic wrap hidden in the lining
of the baggage the TSA called in the FBI
and that section of the airport was
evacuated officials say further
examination of the device determined it
contained two types of incendiary powder
as well as fuses leading FBI agents to
identify it as an explosive the
complaint says the luggage also
contained a can of butane a lighter a
pipe with white powder residue a
wireless drill with cordless batteries
and two outlets taped together with
black tape anytime an explosive gets on
an aircraft if that were to happen and
it was detonated in the air it could be
catastrophic Keith Jeffries is a former
Federal Security director for the TSA
this incident actually is a reason to be
excited that the security process works
after the discovery the airport security
desk paged monthly but according to the
complaint cameras captured him exiting
the terminal just minutes later
now as Gail mentioned muffley was
arrested by the FBI at his home Monday
night he's being Cho he's being charged
with possession of an explosive in an
airport and trying to get explosives on
board an aircraft he's expected to make
his first virtual court appearance later
today Tony
yeah the system seems to have worked
Christina thank you very much